what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are covering the story where Galactus
becomes ultimate Galactus and actually
just becomes ridiculously powerful so
what this does this takes place after
the events of Age of Ultron now for
those of you guys who never saw our
coverage of the original Age of Ultron
story it was basically a bunch of time
hijinks and while the main story itself
doesn't really have anything to do with
Galactus what does happen is that at the
End Wolverine basically breaks time and
what ends up happening is that as soon
as a cascading effect throughout the
Multiverse and as part of this Galactus
is transported to the Ultimate Universe
now what this does is this picks up
right like a maybe a few minutes before
that happens and what it does is it
initially joins up with Rick Jones now
Rick Jones historically speaking in
Marvel Comics in the main Marvel
Universe has always been a relatively
important character depending on what
area you're talking about for example in
the story that we recently covered
Avengers forever he was pretty important
there but by and large he kind of
started off as what was at one point the
friend sidekick of the Incredible Hulk
and then because came a little more
prominent after that in this instance
what you have is still the kind of idea
of Rick Jones being a cosmically powered
being the difference here is that he
hasn't become Captain Marvel yet and
that was the significance is that in the
main Marvel Universe he basically ended
up joining up with Marvel actually
merging into bodies and so much in the
same way that Bruce Banner turns into
the Incredible Hulk and vice versa
Marvel would turn into Rick Jones and
vice versa and the Ultimate Universe is
a little bit different here the reality
is that he is still pretty much a cosmic
being but he was chosen by the Watchers
now the Watchers in the Ultimate
Universe are quite literally just like
poles like just like metal poles I'm not
referring to like Polish people that'd
be a terrible way to say it but they're
basically just like like literally polls
right obelisks if you want to call them
that and they effectively watch they're
very very ambiguous there's very little
that's known about them but they
ultimately chose Rick Jones to become
their new kind of Avatar or protector of
the universe due to a coming event now
this one kind of foreshadows it but it's
not the main event that they're talking
about instead what happens is Rick Jones
is basically teleported to a war between
the cree race and the chatari if you've
seen any of the jatari in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it's basically what
they are in the comics and the thing
about this is that where Rick Jones
initially steps in and actually tries to
kind of like broker the piece to a
degree he's not very successful just
because of the fact that these are two
just like massively warring groups but
in the midst of all that and before any
of them can really understand what's
going on Galactus shows up now this is
not the main Marvel Universe Galactus
this is the ultimate Galactus we are
going to see the main Marvel Universe
Galactus it's really really cool but the
ultimate Galactus was quite literally
just a bunch of sentient ships initially
we didn't really know what the nature of
them was we didn't know exactly how
Galactus function in the Ultimate
Universe or at least where it came from
its function was similar it just
literally traveled the space ways and
just basically consumed everything in
its path but unlike the main Marvel
Universe Galactus that did it in order
to satiate himself because as it's quote
unquote his role in the universe the
Galactus satellite to the Galactus ships
right this kind of swarm that's like a
hundred thousand miles long it's insane
how big it is that what did what what
really happened here is that it was
created by the cree that's one of the
revelations that comes out of this story
is that the cree created Galactus for
the purpose of literally destroying
other worlds so the cree could basically
conquer them what ended up happening is
that everything went sideways and the
Galactus entity ended up basically
becoming self-aware you know kind of
becoming autonomous and now it just
travels a space ways destroying every
form of sentient life that it can find
and then draining the energy out of the
center of every planet leaving it a dead
husk so sure like the in terms of their
actions it's the exact same between the
main Marvel Universe and uh the Ultimate
Universe versions of Galactus but their
motivations are different here the
biggest thing and really one of the big
similarities is that when ultimate
Galactus shows up everybody just really
panics and tries to flee for their lives
the cree for the most part stand their
ground because as the ones who
originally created it albeit you know
they're basically becoming you know that
was it Galactus becoming the
Frankenstein's monster at the end of the
day they still try to destroy right they
still try to fight it off when they can
where they can that kind of a thing but
ultimately the Galactus vessel is no
real you know it's it's way too much for
anybody here but what makes things even
more complicated is that where you do
have Rick Jones who steps in he does
what he can they're all met by basically
a temporal flux this is the result of
wolverines screwing up time at the end
of Age of Ultron literally a temporal
hole is ripped in space and time and the
main Marvel Universe Galactus emerges
and when he does they don't really know
how to respond no one really knows what
to do and even Galactus himself shows up
here and it's just like someplace new
someplace different and then the
immediate response of the ultimate
Galactus robots is to merge with him
right so literally say like consume
right consume new energy source but they
ultimately merge with him a lot of this
kind of seems to be because while they
saw him as a sentient being and they
registered stored a massive amount of
power once they came into contact with
him we're not really given a direct
indication as to why maybe it's just
because they realize that hey like this
guy is more or less us in a different
reality but like our power signatures
are similar we're greater than the sum
of our parts if we merge we'll be more
powerful together regardless of the
motivation what ends up happening is
they fully merge with Galactus and then
you get this pretty beastly looking
version of Galactus like he looks pretty
dope but as soon as that happens he
immediately sends the Swarm out which
now more or less acts as his Herald and
just says find sentient worlds for me to
consume enter nor in rad now nor in rad
of course the Silver Surfer showing up
here here's one of the cool things about
his character so when the Silver Surfer
was initially introduced in the Ultimate
Universe we didn't really know a whole
lot about him right I mean for the most
part we assumed his history was intact
like the main Marvel Universe where he
came from Zin law and all that kind of
stuff and that was more or less verified
where Marvel totally screwed the pooch
is they basically took the character of
psycho man from the main over Universe
when he was in the Ultimate Universe he
was the ruler of Zen law and then in
turn he was brought to Earth by the
Silver Surfer who at that point was
called the silver Searcher who had
basically been discovered by Reed
Richards because Reed was trying to
create a cosmic Hue using a star and he
ended up capturing the Silver Surfer
instead but literally Silver Surfer
brings uh brings the psycho man to Earth
in order to bring quote unquote peace to
Earth only to find out that the
psychoman is basically using mind
control so he turns against him and then
that was more or less the origin of
silver silver it was terrible it was
really really really bad and I like I
hated it like I absolutely despise it I
would rather we just never got an origin
of the Silver Surfer and he was just a
guy who was out there and like that's it
but the big thing about this is that
when Galactus shows up and when he first
encounters the Silver Surfer he
immediately recognizes him but doesn't
recognize him right he's like I know you
but the one that I know is the one from
my universe you're just a guy who's here
but even the one in my universe is a
nuisance so I'm going to you assume that
you're the same but the thing about this
is that the surfer's been around long
enough and has witnessed enough things
over the course of the universe to
recognize the danger that Galactus poses
now that's one of the things that I want
to specify here and the main Marvel
Universe of Marvel Comics right Earth
616 you get all kinds of crazy stuff the
cosmic entities and you have Galactus
the Gods like just a great big huge dude
who consumes worlds and stuff like that
the Ultimate Universe is a lot more
deconstructed and tamed down you don't
really get the same kind of Flights of
Fancy that you get in the main Marvel
Universe right there's drastic
differences between the two so that's
why what you're seeing here especially
with regarding the Silver Surfer seems a
lot more realistic as opposed to just
more what kind of crazy stuff can we
cook up right that's why you see major
differences here it is cool though
because a surfer in realizing the danger
that Galactus poses literally tries to
race off and find somebody or or some
measure of a way in order to defeat this
guy the problem is the first world that
Galactus seeks out out to consume is the
world that Rick Jones has fled to with
refugees from the war between the cree
and the chatari in order to basically
provide a kind of sick day right Medical
Aid so they basically are in like a
world of pain and so galantis just like
sends down the entirety of the Galactus
horde on this world now Rick Jones is
able to kind of hold things off to a
degree but there's not a whole lot he
can do permanently because remember
because of the nature of these little
vessels all they want to do is consume
sentient life and they consume
everything right like organic life
animals human beings sentient beings
aliens the whole nine yards plant matter
right like whales in the ocean
everything gets consumed right
everything gets destroyed and so they
immediately attack Rick Jones and they
start siphoning off his energy now if
given the ability they would also
consume his physical flesh but Silver
Surfer arrives just in time to save him
and where they are able to hold off the
Galactus swarm even if only temporarily
that's when they come face to face with
Galactus himself now where Galactus ends
up seizing the Silver Surfer if more out
of curiosity than anything of course the
Silver Surfer basically instructs uh
instructs Rick Jones to get people
evacuated as fast as they can but the
other part of this is that the cree have
prepared what's basically an Ultimate
Weapon in their mind that because of the
fact that the Galactus swarm was their
creation they spent eons trying to find
a way to destroy it and the most
effective way to do that is to lure it
to a singular location the entirety of
the Swarm and then set a star to go
supernova and obliterate the entirety of
the Galactus swarm in one Fell Swoop
using the astronomical heat and pressure
of an exploding star the problem with
this is that it's not just the Galactus
swarm anymore it's the power of Galactus
and the power Cosmic combined with the
power of the Swarm it's like Galactus
being doubly powerful right like it's
like two times Galactus right he's just
amped up to like stage two so it's not
going to be as easy to defeat him as it
would normally be assumed by the cree
they are able to detonate the star they
are able to set it to go supernova and
where Rick Jones and really Silver
Surfer end up fleeing and they basically
arrive on Earth literally Rick Jones is
immediately told by The Watcher Galactus
is alive the destruction of the star was
not enough to kill him and while the
Watchers necessarily say it as much his
the other part of his message is like
and you were stupid to believe that it
would so the thing about this is that
right galatus continuing on this
actually leads to the Revelation that
when they were teleported away one of
the Galactus ships traveled with them
and then immediately he starts attacking
the immediate vicinity around earth
right like the general vicinity around
there now for the most part it's just
like one ship it is exceedingly powerful
right it's wildly capable Silver Surfer
and Rick Jones aren't necessarily able
to destroy it on their own but the
bigger part of this is that we basically
end up switching over to Marvel now
again Marvel in the main Marvel Universe
has long since died of cancer but he was
at one point a Cree soldier who
basically joined up with the superheroes
on Earth where he was initially tasked
to basically conquer the Earth he ended
up turning against the cree siding with
the superheroes and saving the Earth the
reality here is that this version of
Marvel is not that dissimilar right his
origin is more intertwined with the
nature of Galactus and he's one of the
very few people out there in the
universe who know the true origin of the
Galactus swarm but the reality here is
that he's ultimately called to duty he
largely operates on Earth he is a
superhero on Earth but when he shows up
here alongside norn rad and Rick Jones
facing off against this one Galactus
ship that's when he realized how in the
world could this thing possibly get here
because if one's here and while it's
totally annihilated by Marvel his
response is that if one's here it's part
of a hive mind it's already sent a
signal out to the rest of the Galactus
horde that like there's life here and so
literally the rest of them are just
going to come flooding in and that's
exactly what happens that basically
Galactus starts making his way toward
towards the earth now there is a bit of
debate and there is some kind of
discussion between Rick Jones and Marvel
himself Rick Jones was chosen by the
Watchers to be a protector of the
universe but the reality here is that he
just doesn't really believe in himself
and he's never really believed in what
he was capable of and in fact his role
is one that he's consistently fled from
it was a major focal point of his
character in these early days in
contrast to that Marvel is a trained
Cree Soldier he's exceedingly capable
and so instead of looking at Rick Jones
and seeing a counterpart he looks at
Rick Jones and he sees a coward and of
course Rick Jones basically ends up
fleeing but once Rick Jones kind of gets
back to force Hills in Queens New York
he ends up finding out that his really
long time friend Peter Parker is dead
because this takes place after the
events of the death of Ultimate
Spider-Man again Rick Jones has been off
of Earth all this time he didn't know
that happened but the reality is not
even knowing that Peter Parker was even
Spider-Man in the first place that it
kind of starts to jog him a little bit
and kind of gets him into a position in
in realizing that if his friend Peter
Parker who he always considered to be
just kind of like this nerdy kid who
never would have like stepped up and
done anything really capable because it
never seemed like he would have been
been able to do that if he could step in
become a superhero and even sacrifice
his life in the process right dying in
order to save the world as best he could
or at least Stave off his villains then
wise Rick Jones cowering in the face of
such astronomical power that dwarfs what
Spider-Man is capable of with a much
larger larger Charter to Encompass that
power right to go along with that power
and so with that bit of a kind of
motivational Jog and even after talking
to like Mary Jane Watson right who's
like get it together man like Peter
Parker could just like crawl up
buildings and he could swing around with
webbing and punch really hard like
you're a cosmic being go be a cosmic
being right like Peter Parker would be
ashamed of you I mean she doesn't say it
that way right I mean she says it like
you should really have more confidence
in yourself like that kind of thing
right but she's literally telling him
get it together right so like once he
has that kind of confidence boost and
that bit of motivation he travels back
directly to where the Silver Surfer and
Marvel are and when he does he literally
starts harnessing the full power of what
he's capable of and starts going
toe-to-toe with Galactus now here's the
thing let me like just to clarify here
it's not changing anything right I mean
it's not like the arrival of Rick Jones
here with a newfound level of confidence
after talking to Mufasa and he says you
are my son the one true king it's not as
though like the tables have turned no
they're all getting destroyed like I
mean they're all getting absolutely wret
it's just he's getting wrecked with more
confidence than he had before which I
don't know that's a good thing or a bad
thing but the bigger part of this is
that Marvel actually is able to hold off
or at least uh able to Stave off some of
the forces of the Galactus swarm once
they descend on him the problem is that
given the vast amount of power he has at
his disposal given his suit of armor the
power that comes with it and everything
else then ultimately he ends up
succumbing to his injuries he basically
eyes they do teleport him to holla in
order to basically at least down to the
planet itself because Galactus is
literally at the home world of hollow
right the Homeworld of the cree but once
they get him down there he ultimately
succumbs to his injuries and then in
turn Rick Jones dons the helmet of
Marvel and becomes the new Captain
Marvel and so now they're back onto the
back onto the to the the offense again
Rick Jones is more powerful than he was
before but seemingly it doesn't look
like he's powerful enough in order to be
able to defeat Galactus at least in and
of himself but that's when he gets this
Revelation that within the suit of armor
there is a contingency plan but the
first thing to do is to get the
Innocence to safety because lest we
forget while Galactus is here at Hala it
doesn't make any sense to just kind of
wait around and see what happens and
hope they live the smartest thing to do
is to evacuate and that's what's
literally been going on they've been
just loading up all these evacuation
ships and getting people out of holla as
fast as possible not everybody's going
to be able to make it but most everybody
is and so in light of this with these
ships basically evacuating a portals
opened by Rick Jones which allows the
ships to pass through and then leave
this immediate space and the reason for
that is twofold the first is that Rick
Jones realizes the fight between himself
and Galactus and Silver Surfer will
destroy the planet of challah but it'll
also destroy whatever surrounding star
systems happen to be there just due to
the sheer amount of power that they have
the other part of this is that there's
still something like 32 million people
in this area and that when the
contingency plan is offered by the armor
to Rick Jones which is the Galactus
killer initiative that the fatality
count would be about 32 million and so
where Rick Jones initially stays off and
says no like we can't do that we cannot
let all the or allow all these people to
be destroyed by the power of galantis at
the end of the day it seemingly doesn't
make a difference but then suddenly The
Watcher appears and then tells Rick
Jones there is a kind of caveat a way
you could work around this by basically
moving Galactus to a location with there
is no other life out there the Galactus
swarm has destroyed so much of the
universe there's huge portions of
reality of of the universe itself where
there's no sentient life because those
worlds have been drained dry that the
the stars are still there but like
there's no sentient life there and so in
in realizing the capability of that
basically Rick Jones opens a portal that
pulls himself and Galactus along with
the Galactus swarm through and then In
This Moment fires off the Galactus
killing shot and just blows Galactus to
Pieces right blows like ultimate
Galactus to bits here's the funny thing
about this right once the whole thing is
done this kind of unceremonious ending
this seems to happen in the blink of an
eye right once it's done that you
basically have Rick Jones who's kind of
having this bit of a conversation with
the Watcher right the day saved
everything's okay the cree are
celebrating and it's all said and done
and so as he's talking to the Watcher he
asked the question did I do it and the
response to the Watcher is Yes Rick
Jones you stop the Galactus swarm
removed it from that fight and so he
says so everything's back to normal and
the response to the Watcher is no your
journey has just begun and the response
of Rick is okay like didn't we just save
all of reality and the response to the
Watcher is no you merely prolonged that
dimension's lifespan and when Rick asks
like what do you mean that Dimension the
response to the Watcher is like you
ripped a hole between universes right
you are outside of known reality and so
when Rick says okay well I mean I guess
that's fine we can figure it out but at
least we destroyed the Galactus entity
the response to the Watcher is no you
didn't you destroyed the Galactus swarm
but you didn't actually destroy Galactus
himself and when the response of Rick
Jones is well then what's he gonna do
the answer of the Watcher is the one
thing that makes the most sense he has
to feed so he's traveling to the most
energy rich Place throughout the
entirety of the universe he's traveling
to Earth but that's not your problem and
so what happens here this story of
course being called cataclysm it
transitions to Earth so for those of you
guys who remember that scene at the very
end of the Age of Ultron on story where
Galactus appears on Earth and Miles
Morales sees him that's when this takes
place Galactus from the main Marvel
universe is showing up on Earth in the
Ultimate Universe which means now the
Ultimate Avengers ultimate Spider-Man
all those guys have to deal with a world
destroyer from a universe that they've
never been to but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end thank you all for watching and I
will catch you all later
peace